[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on veut pas de chômage on veut pas dire
on va travailler puis on atteint juste
le plein du gouvernement des
travailleurs de l'aviation ont manifesté
aujourd'hui à toronto à montréal pour
demander de l'aide
une stratégie nationale pour le secteur
aérien manifestations à l'aéroport
pearson de toronto et devant les bureaux
du ministre des transports marc garneau
à westmount
notre invité ce soir fuster free le
ministre fédéral des finances qui a
prononcé un discours aujourd'hui devant
la chambre de commerce du montréal
métropolitain discours virtuel faut-il
le préciser
bonsoir adam freeland bonsoir votre
gouvernement est très fortement
intervenue pour soutenir les canadiens
depuis le début de la crise
mais non on entend les travailleurs du
secteur aérien par exemple se sentent
oubliés
est ce que vous prévoyez annoncé de
l'aide pour le secteur aérien dans votre
mise à jour économique cherhal si vous
me permettez je veux préciser un petit
peu parce que les travailleurs du
secteur à rien comme tous les
travailleurs autour de notre pays ne
sont pas oubliés et je veux souligner
que la subvention salle arrière est
utilisé par les travailleurs par les
entreprises dans tous les secteurs du
canada parlant du sou 26 ans à l'arrière
le secteur arrêt n a à utiliser plus
d'une milliard du dollars
avec la subvention salariale alors c'est
beaucoup c'est beaucoup d'argent
même en pleine pandémie alors que le
fédéral est là maintenant pour le
secteur vous avez raison que nous
comprenons qu'il y à des secteurs il y à
des entreprises autour du canada qui
font face à des restrictions
particulières à cause de la crise
sanitaire à cause de la quarantaine ou
la cause des restrictions à la frontière
à cause des mesures dures et confinement
qui sont pris et que j'ai appuyé
fortement par les profs installant il ya
dix entreprises des secteurs qui font
face à des restrictions particulier et
on travaille maintenant pour trouver des
façons pour aider ces secteurs aussi ok
vous dites que vous avez un plan une
boussole dites vous alors que les taux
d'intérêt très faibles vous permettre
quand même d'emprunter d'investir en ce
moment dans l'économie il ya quand même
des gens qui sont inquiets de
l'endettement et qui se disent qu'il
faut arrêter qu'il faut arrêter quelque
part que ça prend une limite
est ce qu'il ya une limite à ce que vous
pouvez dépenser pour soutenir les
canadiens
quand j'ai dit aujourd'hui gérald je
suis d'accord qu'il ya une limite et
qu'il n'y a pas des chèques en blanc qu
en même temps je suis convaincu
qu'aujourd'hui il est absolument
nécessaire pour le fédéral d'appuyer les
travailleurs les entreprises l'économie
canadienne ce n'est pas une vous avez
commencé vos questions en demandant est
ce que le fait de galles est prête à
appuyer nos industries et c'est la
question que l'on pose les canadiens
autour de nos pays et ils ont raison
nous sommes en pleine pandémie nous
avons une crise sanitaire et je suis
fier des canadiens canadiennes
nous faisons ce que nous devons faire
pour lutter contre cette pandémie
mais les aînés ne reconnaît pas aussi
positif si je peux je peux je veux juste
finir la phase une phase très très vite
il n'est pas possible de demander aux
gens de rester à la maison de demander
aux entreprises de fermer ses portes à
cause de la pandémie sans les aider
c'est ce que je pense et pour cette
raison le fédéral est là et sera là êtes
vous d'accord
c'est à dire je n'ai pas être d'accord
ou non je sais qu'il ya des gens qui
vous pose des questions pour avoir plus
d aide mais qui en a qui s'inquiètent du
déficit est ce que la crise actuelle
peut devenir une crise d'endettement une
crise de finances publiques au canada
non on a les ressources de faire
qu'on doit faire je suis absolument
convaincu que ça le canada à entrer la
crise avec une position fiscale très
forte
comme vous avez constaté les taux
d'intérêts centre est à bas niveau
aujourd'hui on peut faire ce qu'on doit
faire
vous identifiez par exemple la déflation
comme étant un risque au canada
présentement une baisse généralisée des
prix dites nous pourquoi
c'est un risque c'est une très très
longue réponse mais à je peux visionner
les images mais je vais effet en général
gerald je pense que même avant la
pandémie
on a vu une situation dont tout le monde
industrialisé à queue on a eu un
problème que on peut à décrire comme la
stagnation séculaire que on a des
problèmes avec la croissance c'est la
plus grand problème d'aujourd'hui et
pour cette raison comme je l'expliqué
aujourd'hui je pense que l'offre quelque
chose qu'on doit faire aujourd'hui c'est
lutter contre le corps en effet russes
mais la deuxième chose qu'on doit faire
c'est avoir un plan d'investissement
pour avoir une relance forte une relance
gros boost une relance qui a aidé la
compétitivité du canada à l'échelle
mondiale on doit avoir que la croissance
la croissance économique
c'est la réponse à nos problèmes parce
que la quête que vous avez c'est de voir
l'économie ralentir ralentir beaucoup
parce qu'on n'agirait pas assez beaucoup
d'entreprises qui ferait faillite
beaucoup de gens qui perdraient leur
emploi et avoir pendant des années une
reprise très difficile sur le plan
économique
non je pense que en faire face
aujourd'hui à une crise économique très
particulière une crise qui a été causé
par une pandémie exogènes est la nôtre
crise aujourd'hui est très différent des
autres crises économiques que vous et
moi nous avons vous dans notre vie en
tant que journaliste économique
alors aujourd'hui on doit commencer avec
la crise sanitaire de la lutte contre le
virus
on doit faire tous nécessaires incluant
avoir l'appui économique essentiel mais
après ça la chose la plus importante ce
sera un plan pour la relance et le
gouvernement est en train maintenant de
travailler sur cette peau vous allez
présenter votre mise à jour économique
budgétaire en novembre est-ce qu'on a
une date non ou peut-être ou peut-être
en date mais on va pas un an c'est la
date soit on aurait aimé avoir le scoop
mais on va attendre
en attendant est ce que le résultat de
l'élection présidentielle aux états unis
aura un impact sur l'économie du canada
et sur vos choix budgétaires j'ai écouté
votre transmission sur cette question
évidemment on a les résultats des
élections aux états unis ont toujours en
effect pour le canada et ce sera le cas
avec cette élection
ah je veux assurer les canadiens
canadiennes que notre gouvernement est
absolument prête à toutes les
possibilités
tous les éventualités et est ce que vous
préférez une éventualité à une autre ce
n'est pas pour moi est ce n'est pas pour
le gouvernement du canada a dû faire une
choix qui doit être une chouette pour
que les américains très bien madame
freeland merci beaucoup pour cette
entrevue ce soir c'est un plaisir de
vous recevoir
merci beaucoup gérable